it is so good to see you I'll tell you
whenever you read the Gotham Awards and
I mean what a journey you've been on
you've been collecting Awards here and
there and look at you your latest
it's incredible where's your friend
Oscar though where's Oscar he's at home
he's at home yeah
uh he's in my uh in in my home office uh
he's my best new best friend I love him
so so much for for 40 years almost uh so
he's finally uh been able to come home
which is which is great
have just been celebrating your journey
it's been miraculous and then you know
for this honor we've got Tom Hiddleston
who wrote your tribute what's that mean
to you because Loki himself right now
that was really special because I I had
the best of time uh shooting Loki season
2 with him it was one of the best
Adventures that I've had uh and I you
know he's just so good at what he does
he's a kind human being he's a great
actor I've learned so much from him he
inspires me uh so for him to write that
tribute uh that was very very special
that's incredible we'll see you reunite
with your everything everywhere all at
once some of your cast members from
there for American Born Chinese
american-born Chinese is coming out oh
my God May 24th so good and then Indiana
Jones this summer might we see you win a
cameo well uh you know I I want to say
yes but but no but no but here's the
thing who's in the case I don't want I
don't want to disappoint the fans uh
I've joked about it all the time but you
know reuniting with Harrison after 38
years that was very special and of
course when of all the years to have
them present the Best Picture award at
this year's Academy Awards that was
something that was what that will always
be one of the most memorable nights of
my life and I can't wait to see him Don
the Fedora again and crack that that
whip one more time I will be first in
line to watch this right I'm sure you
will baby have fun tonight thank you so
much
[Music]
thank you
foreign